[Musique]
mes très chers frères nous allons vous
parler ce soir d'un sujet qui notait un
parti à man à carreaux à coeur à coeur
c'est un sujet devant lequel plus d'un
se sont tenues à coeur à carreaux à
carros est exact je remercie vous êtes
tombé à trèfle à pic
ap voici donc ce soir des sept péchés
capitaux
c'est un sujet riche sera forcément avec
des capitaux ses péchés qu'elles sont il
est bien dans leur nous avons
premièrement la luxure n'ont quà la
luxure n'est pas un péché capital 6 mai
pendant l'ordre oui vous avez raison
c'est plutôt le désordre
non non ça veut dire par là que la
luxure n'est pas le premier péché
j'avais envie que ce soit la luxure ça
n'est pas longue vie non plus alors quel
est l'ordre est bien à l'ordre ses
l'avarice la colère l'envié la
gourmandise la luxure l'orgueil à la
paresse ça c'est l'ordre oui
alphabétique mais ce qui ne veut pas
dire que si on commence par la luxure
aux soins analphabètes et ouvrages sur i
premier péché l'avarice s'il vous plaît
pas trop musique pour l'as bari ce
qu'est ce que l'avarice et bien c'est
quand un type qui a hérité de 50
millions nous avons de l'argent pour un
chat peut avoir d'occasions et quand
celui qui vous propose de vous louer
pour y mettre vos économistes y compris
la location par rembourser l'argent
qu'ils ont emprunté pour acheter son
coffre deuxième péché la colère
[Musique]
quand un type qui a hérité de 50
millions la vente de l'argent voire 5 en
faveur de casion et qu'ensuite vous
propose ou louer pour y mettre vos
économies c'est le prix de location par
vous rembourser l'argent qu'il envoie
tes bras chez son coffre alors la tête
en coller à ce qu'est ce qui vous arrive
d'une colère froide troisième péché
l'envi
[Musique]
quand un type qui elle avait un sens et
dans la réalité de 50 millions vous en
prendre de l'argent pour acheter comme
renfort de cars et qu'ensuite vous
propose de louer pour y mettre vos
économies y compris la location par vous
rembourser l'argent que l'on voudrait
qu'on a acheté son coffre
alors là vous avez envie d'avoir envie
d'en kg et son sens des affaires [ __ ]
vous vous êtes envieux et pourtant je
m'habille jeunes quatrième pêcher la
gourmandise
[Musique]
quand un type qui a hérité de 50
millions nous en demandent de l'argent
pour acheter un courant fort de
castillon et constitue vous propose de
louer pour y mettre vos économies
j'avais pris la location il part vous
rembourser l'argent qu'il a emprunté
pour acheter son coffre ou 100 g avec
l'eau à la bouche qu'avec 50 millions
vous auriez pu vous payez deux tonnes de
profiteroles 500 kg terrine du chef
mangerait bien un petit bonbon pas pour
la terrine c'est la gourmandise
[Musique]
cinquième péché la luxure ans daddy
priorité de 50 millions l'enfant de
l'argent dans ce coffre fort d'occasion
et qu'ensuite vous propose de vous louer
pour y mettre aux économies jury du prix
de la location pour avoir osé d'argent
vous pensez les yeux exorbités qu'avec
50 millions et que vous payez sophia
loren voile alors s'il andré landry
raquel welch est là non pas que les bas
qui n'ont pas de c'est pas mon gamin
s'en tenir là une grande brune king kong
l'orgueil c'est après 6e péché d'orgueil
[Musique]
madame mademoiselle monsieur patate et
priorités de 50 millions l'envol de
l'argent pour un jeu qu'on peut avoir de
cohésion est ensuite vous propose de
vous lever pour y mettre vos économies
c'est vraiment une agrégation pas
rembourser l'argent de la vente et leurs
acteurs aux coffres mais vous dites que
c'est ta pauvre type qui n'est même pas
sorti de polytechnique et gaz avant de
regagner son enfant millions que vous
auriez placés en suisse
[Musique]
septième péché la paresse en
cultiver la paresse c'est être paresseux
et être paré ce qu'est ce que c'est être
paresseux et être avare de colère dans
vie de gourmandise la luxure et
d'orgueil
autrement dit la paresse et la mère de
tous les vices d'où le proverbe
telle mère tel fils à
[Musique]